yeah it's Friday and that means it's
time for Dan bond Gino to explode this
shows favorite former cop and author of
the book exonerated the failed takedown
a President Donald Trump by the swamp is
here to round up his top stories of the
week
go get him Dan thank you mark always
good to see you let's start with Story
number three listen mark I've been
getting awfully tired of this fake faux
impeachment not impeachment I don't even
know what you want to call this thing
and apparently a bunch of GOP
congressmen and women got a little bit
talker to this thing too and decided to
the storm the gates of a secret hearing
Adam Schiff and Jerry Nadler been
holding you know mark I've never seen
impeachment like this in my life the
Constitution is pretty clear the House
of Representatives has the sole power to
impeach it doesn't say Jerry Nadler Adam
Schiff the Speaker Nancy Pelosi the
House of Representative Mike you know I
know liberals have a tough time with
English and things but plural
representatives you know and you're not
meant to reach you're not meant to
impeach the guy in a skiff and that the
media thought the storming the atom
shifts the atom shifts different if was
the worst thing since storming the
Bastille
yeah leave your cell phones outside of
the skip we're about to impeach the
president folks everybody number two are
we looking at
try again try again again Hillary 2020
who knows listen mark I've lost
elections it stinks but sometimes mark
it's time to take a hint you know give
him a little week time to move on this
thing may not be for you I left politics
it was in my bag of doughnuts I can't
believe this that a staffer Philippe
Rytas who's not my closest friend on Fox
News if you know what I mean kind of
hint it on whatever shows this week that
there's not a 0% chance that there's a
small chance Hillary could jump in again
can you imagine another shot at the
title for ninth time's the charm Dan you
know it yeah well she she still hasn't
figured out the rules mark she thinks
the popular vote wins the presidency
apparently she probably still thinks the
Atlanta Braves won the 96 World Series
over the Yankees because they outscored
up in the first two games so you may
want to get the rules down before you
think about running again just to note
the pro tip what's your top story that
madam top story of the weeks gotta be
John Brennan who clearly is downing
pepto-bismol like it's Gatorade after a
University of Florida football game this
guy is terrified right now and Mark he's
terrified from one big important Brees
you know I like to joke around a lot too
in this segment of five is important
this guy's in a lot of trouble he has
said openly and publicly on networks
cable TV and otherwise that he didn't
see the dossier until December anybody
can read it mark yeah but that's not
possible because he briefed Harry Reid
and August which for liberals would have
a tough time with the calendar is before
December and when he briefed Harry Reid
Harry Reid wrote a letter afterwards to
the FBI about that briefing containing
information mark that only appeared in
one place the dossier Brennan said he
didn't see till December so you know in
some small limited circles mark we'd
call that a problem and Johnny B is in a
world of trouble right now get the pepto
Johnny you're gonna need it dad dad
you're absolutely right on that because
so that's what got George papadopolis
and my general Flynn sent to death thank
you for that explosion
is it for the night